lien tout le monde sait ce bla bla bla
bla bla on a récemment atteint les 2
millions d'abonnés et c'est un nombre de
dalles et c'est grâce à vous merci tout
le monde merci de vous être abonné à ma
chaîne de regarder les vidéos de jeux
c'est pas de partager des choses avec
moi que ce soit en commentant m'envoyant
des messages par mail ou où tout ça
c'est vraiment un truc de dingue d'avoir
une communauté derrière soi ça fait
vraiment super plaisir c'est pour moi un
rêve qui se réalise parce que comme je
l'aï déjà dit si j'avais commencé
youtube c'est parce que j'étais mal dans
ma peau j'avais pas mal d'acné etc
je me renfermé sur moi-même et dans les
jeux vidéo et je me suis dit plutôt que
de trop fermé et c'est de partager cette
passion avec d'autres gens et
aujourd'hui on en est là deux millions
de personnes c'est énorme ça fait
maintenant pas mal de temps que je pense
à faire une campagne de dons et je me
suis dit que ces deux millions d'abonnés
c'était l'occasion de lancer ça comme je
vous ai dit vous m'avez permis de
réaliser mon rêve et je me suis dit
pourquoi ne pas permettre à d'autres
personnes de réaliser leurs rêves à leur
tour qu'ils vivent quelque chose
d'inoubliable dans leur vie ne serait ce
qu'une journée un instant qu'ils vivent
quelque chose de dingue du coup j'ai
trouvé pas mal d'associations dont le
but est de permettre aux enfants
gravement malades réaliser leur rêve
donc par garde malade j'entends tout ce
qui est cancer tumeur maladie
neurologique même sida a faim les
maladies incurables
au final j'ai choisi l'association
petits princes qui permet donc aux
enfants gravement malades de réaliser
leurs rêves dans plus de ça il apporte
une aide à la famille par exemple s'il
traitement médical de l'enfant est trop
cher eh ben ils vont aider la famille à
financer ce traitement on est 2 millions
personnes on a vraiment la possibilité
entre nos mains de permettre à des
enfants gravement malades de vivre au
moins une journée unique de vivre leur
rêve de vivre un instant inoubliable où
ils seront les plus heureux du monde et
je suis désolé mais pour moi j'ai
réfléchi sur ça et je me suis dit il
faut faire un truc qu'il ya un truc à
faire vraiment j'ai créé une campagne de
dons sur le site
intego qui est un site vraiment fiable
j'ai pas mal cherché et finalement c'est
celui là qui revenait plus sur les
forums etc
c'est très simple vous choisissez le
montant de votre contribution ça va de 5
euros jusqu'à 500 euros et moi à chaque
contribution je propose quelque chose en
échange donc bien évidemment c'est pas
le ce que je vous propose que vous
achetez loin de là moi c'est juste
quelque chose que je vous apporte en
plus pour vous remercier d'avoir donné à
l'association par exemple vous pouvez
gagner une chance de jouer avec moi vous
pouvez avoir une conversation vidéo avec
moi avec moi et d'autres gens voire même
jusqu'à nous rencontrer en vrai avec
d'autres personnes l'objectif de la
campagne est de 20 millions euros et on
a 45 jours pour rassembler 20 mille
euros c'est une somme vraiment énorme je
pense qu'il ya plein d'enfants qui
pourront vivre
grâce à ça on est deux millions de
personnes 20 milles c'est un pur sang de
2 millions on peut vraiment y arriver il
faut juste que tout le monde fasse
l'effort d'aller sur le site ne serait
ce que pour s'y intéresser
puis ensuite prendre une décision si oui
ou non vous donner le montant etc
vous avez le choix je vais toucher
absolument 0% vote aux nations je vous
rassure le but n'est vraiment pas là je
préfère mettre les points sur les i
comme on dit quand on a plus de 80 ans
si vous voulez contribuer à cette
campagne que vous êtes donc un mini
robots mais que malheureusement vous ne
pouvez pas parce que les contributions
se font que par paypal ou alors par
carte de crédit et que vous n'avez pas
de compte paypal et pas de carte de
crédit
je vous invite à demander à votre frère
ou à votre soeur ou à vos parents de
vous prêter son compte paypal ou sa
carte bancaire pour pouvoir faire votre
donation et en échange vous le donne un
billet de 5 ou alors vos parents des du
sein de votre argent poche enfin je sais
pas trop comment ça marche et vous mais
je suis presque sûr que vos parents vous
dire oui si vous leur dites que c'est ou
une association que c'est pour la bonne
cause que c'est pour des enfants
gravement malades leur faire vivre
quelque chose d'unique au moins une fois
dans leur vie
je suis sûr qu'ils vous diront oui
d'accord voici ma carte fils dites vous
bien que votre contribution même ciel et
du montant minimal elle aidera fortement
atteint l'objectif de 20000 euros
encore une fois on est des millions
montrent de quoi on est capable merci